hey guys I'm Greg tell McGee around here
treaty on Instagram hey hey hey when I'm
really sick but I'm here today because I
know you guys keep throwing the requests
and you don't like it when I'm like I'm
sick I don't want to film let's do this
Tony
oh yeah we're gonna do a DeMille I'm up
we're gonna do as well when it goes
again sorry
[Music]
feel free to use the types of diseases
this is long ago I say it down here your
rooms are upstairs Anthony LaPaglia
[Music]
all right she was taken from us and
early great to see you love it girl
again wanted permission to the vigil
doll of experiments forever
[Music]
[Music]
howdy I look pretty scary I just I've
never liked those so of course every
done movie then I say it's just like huh
gah like I don't extra strong when they
like resist that's all I want to know
because like uh who doesn't [ __ ] and
be able to cut out they can make a move
things with their mind - ok that's year
I was like a demon doll basically those
are some good jump scares I like to jump
oh I thought they were good jump scares
you know I always put a man man gotta
get you excited this is a conjuring
universe we got another cinematic
universe it's gonna keep adding it as
like if we could keep blending these
movies yeah I mean Creek Dalton and I
just saw is just gonna take next Chucky
yeah I saw Chuck you in on Jang and that
creeps me out stuff and now this doll
got a demon it really feels like same
thing
not as much that's just the thing I
always feel like damn it I can't any of
these these dolls oh look at even some
said right there chutney versus a Nobel
Hollywood set it up it's interesting cuz
it's like it's about a doll or a little
girl or a demon or multiple you know I
mean it's a hard thing you know if your
parent loses a kid they can always do
the old classic psycho being
like showing their child because they
let me get into Lu yeah just take over
something so I could attack it's all
about setting up for the attack I mean I
really like the movie lights out and I
thought that was a really well directed
movie so I'm interested to see this
because it's the same director okay and
trailers usually give you the jump
scares you know you got to get the jump
scares and the trailers us was so
tickets if they work I think it'll be
more than that I mean you got some
pretty good actors in here Anthony
LaPaglia or whatever the hell his name
is
yeah I've been a little Talia yeah he's
a good actor he sounds like Liam Neeson
in this movie but the thing is I kinda
dropped his voice as much as possible I
mean why did why it's just that one
thing if you just say don't open this
door you tell a child this like I gotta
wait til he's sleeping open that door
without hiding I'm curious to know
whatever once I want to know what
Annabelle wants so you I want other kids
there as animal just want friends that
are just misunderstanding the games and
out playing is she killing people what
what is going gone
they showed like a creepy ass hand at
that one point for the right one joke
scare right yeah some part into it what
actually that's what I'm actually
interested is if it's actually a demon
that could like come out in regular form
and attack people or something seems
like it hops back and forth between
several different forms yeah daughter
dolls you know yeah what is actually
controlling in the dome I mean it looks
a little generic to be honest I mean I
mean look hard to it you're always gonna
have that feeling of just like how
strong is this doll I'm always going
like Chucky I was like okay he has to
have some super strength
or he just has a strength of a regular
man I would kick that gnome any
opportunity I can nowadays now a child
like Oh double stab me I'm sorry
Chucky okay I can't run so I just let me
stab me you know catch me and stabbing
this that's what he was trying to do oh
no these I remember Chucky is trying to
take over another child we go to I was
like what are you the dog robbers let it
out
anyway I mean looks a little generic but
I think if it'll be fine
I mean I have to give like the first
liner was terrible it wasn't the first
one yet like good generic dog scary yeah
everyone's Oh inedible that's why the
only way I feel like it could change
that up is you get to start seeing more
the demon just to kind of be like okay
it's not the doll we have to worry about
it's this crazy creature doubt it'll
really get a understanding a personality
of Antebellum this one she's a whiny
little [ __ ] subscribe to the real
rejects Tony's freezing on Instagram I
need to make a nap
badly tonight I'm gonna sink man up tele
I want the pity I want the pity I've
been I can just even my voice a little
bit
good yeah that sounds like I I can't
make it into work today